so the university often hosts events
especially in the forum because it's a
big debate on coasts hello I don't think
I've ever seen anything quite as mundane
as the let's not work in this part of
the video
Simon discusses his PhD thesis chapter
by chapter this may prove to be boring
to some viewers
we in an attempt to make this section
more interesting he includes footage of
himself falling over between every
chapter so I'm currently about 6 weeks
away from having to hand in my thesis as
in that's a literal deadline I need to
hand in by then or I can't now and I'm
in this situation because basically code
didn't work further down the line and
probably I would have finished by now if
I wasn't doing so many things like
singing and YouTube I fully accept that
but you know I wanted to do those things
so I have like six weeks to put together
a thesis and my thesis is going to be
built up six chapters chapter one is
going to be an introduction that I will
write at the very end but basically to
set up the events of thesis from a
narrative perspective you know I need to
know what I'm going to talk about so
that'll happen at the end and it'll take
like a day to write it can be very short
chapter 2 is written that's my
background chapter and that is about 35
40 pages of everything you need to know
in order to understand the thesis so the
idea is that a thesis should be
understandable to somebody who's not an
expert in your field but has the kind of
the basic knowledge so it's pitch that
somebody who has a physics degree or a
master's degree or sort of some
qualification in meteorology taking you
from the basic equations then
specifically more and more specific
until you get to dynamic coupling of the
stratosphere and troposphere in the
polar regions using a potential
vorticity framework like you kind of
have to do a bit of funneling for that
but that's written Boise is holding up
just about chapter 3 is probably the
most important chapter which is the
theory it's what we're proposing which
is our plunge of hypothesis and math
that's associated with that the mass and
the mass and that's also written
borrowing a little bit at the end that
will probably need to be reworked and
there's bits of both and chapter 2 which
need to be tweaked and like figures that
do need to be rerun with different I
basically have high resolution data now
but that really won't take long those
two chapters done basically so that
leads me six weeks to do chapters four
five and six but chapter four I have
done a section of already and there are
two the two other sections of it
basically just require me to do a long
series of runs and to be honest I'm done
waiting for a bunch of code to start
working which I might have just cracked
because I think correctly theorem we're
pretty short pressure isn't meant to be
negative and when that code starts
working they will kind of the results
will fill themselves I've actually got
all the scripts ready it's like a link
in the chain that I just need to reforge
and when that's done those bits of the
chapter will be filled that really won't
take long to do
then chapter 5 is the unknown quantity
chapter 5 is basically probably could be
quite short by the stage it's going to
be taking the results of chapter 4 and
then applying it probably to a kind of
prediction method saying we know
identify give it within our framework
let's say identify well this means if
you see this in the atmosphere this
means that this normally happens so
let's kind of test that in the real
world rather than in like our idealized
model so that might be a quite short
chapter like maybe even like 10 15 pages
and he's got to be pleased whoever that
and then lastly chapter 6 which is the
conclusion and like the introduction
I'll write that at the very end so the
meat of my thesis I've written about if
you include all the governs like the
bibliography introduction tables all
that kind stuff I think I'm sitting on
about 90 to 95 pages at the moment and I
want to aim for about 130 140 pages but
when you're putting figures in a lot of
that kind of writes itself and with
introduction in conclusion like I say
they weren't taken on to write and they
will Pat things out by probably bout 10
pages in total so you and my supervisor
probably may be a little bit concerned
but to be honest my supervisor isn't
that concerned so you know fingers
crossed everything's gonna go to plan
this is going to be stressful and I'll
be honest I'm filming this having not
had a single day off work for the past
three weeks however long it's been I've
been coming in on the weekend and I've
been staying in to a like seven o'clock
getting here before 9:00 where I can
apart from last week we're doing the
sing in which case I was trying to fit
it around the singing yeah this is gonna
be intense but it's doable so the
current plan is gonna stay here until
I can't five a little bit leaving a
little bit early and then down alright
and go to pictures and we're gonna go
see Kristin ovens new film Dunkirk first
thing got my work to do so to give you
some perspective that was a really
valuable work day I have the entire time
better next to not been able to run my
pipe is frozen I have computed here
because I've not been able to install a
particular library except permission
because I'm not like the Super User like
the administrator but today someone in
the office suggested a workaround which
was to create what's called a virtual
environment which is kind of like
building a fake computer within the
computer that you either have permission
to install stuff in because it's not the
real computer that makes sense so I now
have the luxury of being able to run
stuff on a computer there's more
powerful on laptop and also it means I
can use the laptop at the same time I've
just been particularly recently a real
problem because the stuff I'm running on
my laptop pretty intensive and it was
easy to like run it overnight and well
yeah also be able to do this stuff at
the same time it's pretty valuable
however more importantly in a way kind
of similar to the Peavy problems I was
having before my current issue is
comparing fluxes that are predicted by
changes in pressure with those that are
protected by like saying it's literally
seeing how much mass is pushed over a
boundary and they're not matching up and
I don't know which one was wrong and I
think today I've identified that it's
the pressure ones that are wrong because
I compared that to another index that
should match up with it it really
doesn't so that's a win for analysis
it's not gonna fix the problem there
right and I just need to do a little bit
of printing okay so good coding work
done some sleuthing done I worked how
where the problem lies I'm pretty sure
now with one section of the PhD did some
adulting that's some paper work reply to
a bunch of emails now let's go see a
movie
so we're about to go and see Kristen
owns a new film Dunkirk which as I'm
getting rave reviews and I'm excited I'm
so excited
interestingly your your GPS on you yeah
I after the dar Knight Rises and
interstellar
I am somewhat dubious yeah so we're
going to come back and sit down in like
three
I'm ready to see a film that I'm excited
about and not be disappointed by it
David Roy but we won't have that they
might not have the same thing and Zimmer
you're not gonna disappoint to know and
you're not gonna disappoint Harry Styles
you are not gonna disagree I think it
might even be wally pfister as well as
the DP who did the Dark Knight really so
it might be like they written by
basically the exact same creative team
right we're gonna go and go and see the
film we'll be back in a couple of hours
right
two hours later unbelievable that was
just we didn't say anything to each
other till about like ten minutes into
our walk home yeah like we couldn't say
anything there was there was as perfect
it was and an even like to give it
praise all the feels wrong
you know what I mean it's a film the
rare film that we had an awful lot of
hype about yeah and overwhelmingly
delivered I think it might be the finest
anti-war wolf film I've ever seen yeah
sure it was for sure for me I mean the
first thing I said one of the first
things that idea was comparing how I
felt watching Saving Private Ryan for
the first time and watching dunkirk for
the first time just infinitely more
moving I think I said to you from a
cinematography perspective I undertand
masterful just how god I think it's a
it's a better film than Saving Private
Ryan which is saying a lot because it
was one of my favorite films they use
and I think it had we were talking about
I think the reason that Saving Private
Ryan I had more an emotional impact
needs because it was the first time I
realized that you know it would've been
me in that situation I'm John yeah I
mean obviously the same advice of
Dunkirk and I was saying to like how I
think we both as as British people
coming at it from that perspective and
Cokely it's just so it was also a
subject a cultural event that was
handled in a very British way in the
same way that Spielberg handled the
events of Omaha Beach in a very American
way so everything about acting music we
were taught music - a phenomenal school
from answer yeah he's been it's been
acclaimed as his best musical work yet
completely agree the use of Nimrod from
the Enigma Variations in into it and
there's a particular moment when Lori
can't ruin it although this is before
moving out for weeks by the time it's
comes out there's a particular moment
where it just swells in and what yeah
rained yeah I can't think of anything
else to say I want to see you again for
the first time yeah
[Music]
don't know what it is about today like
maybe it's because actually got a good
night's sleep last night but I am just
completely exhausted I mean I've been
thinking about stuff really hard today
so maybe I'm just a bit drained so I
haven't filmed very much today because
I've just been focusing on work and
continuing my stuff from yesterday well
basically I realized that it was this
pressure index that was wrong rather
than the constructive one with the mass
fluxes and then burrowing down deeper
into that I was sort of comparing
because I have to do some manipulation
to the pressure first and comparing that
to what the raw data is and I'm getting
stuff that doesn't make any sense like
it's really it's it's really annoying me
because it's doing stuff it shouldn't do
and it's doing stuff that's preventing
me from getting work done and I'm
running out of time and I'm also burning
up time to cross the road look both ways
kids maybe like me yeah definitely the
stage now where I am always little
delays are building up like I haven't
got much time left and I'm very
conscious of time pressures and it's
doing stuff that I can't explain and
also some of the issues I'm asking other
people's nay can't explain anyway now
I'm going to pick Pixar garlic because
we're going to didn't in town and then
we've got a funny thing shaved and
that's because we're about to shoot a
video where there is this Lily as pixel
girl and there's done that one's very
that's what the video is gonna be about
[Laughter]
so we just finished shooting the makeup
video as you can see is rather late and
we've got a wiki cast or a call tomorrow
I still getting used to work upset right
I don't know if this is something that
girls but suffer my forehead is super
sweaty and I've been powered and
everything but like everything else is
fine up here newfound respect for girls
thank you so much Lily this will also go
in the video Thank You Lily for doing
our makeup man she's nailed it that oh
you need to do your lips again do
so did we don't put a little bit on the
pad right okay lift something yes
tailor-make oh so that's probably
nothing okay
[Music]
yeah Wow yeah right we just recorded a
podcast it's much less than I wanted it
to be because that was a long podcast
but we had our first case of fanfiction
yeah it was really good
we had one about me being at the time
traveller with large foreheads with
massive forehead what was the way that
your forehead was described in the other
one let me find it he was at wick of the
youth thanks mate balanced only by the
humbly omnipotent weight of his forehead
that is a glorious phrase I love that
I'm getting that on a t-shirt I've got
to say guys I never have fan fiction
written about me and now that I have
it's weird but it's great we probably
shouldn't be encouraging this because
we're gonna get some really weird stuff
but well this will be coming out ages
afterwards but hopefully the weekly cast
has gone from strength to strength we
love doing it as super easy for me to
add it as well right from like a time
perspectives that's why sass is my entry
into the pocket into the story
[Music]
very sure at this stage I sign for more
of your packages than you thought that's
yours
I'm cheap me there you go
it's a stand for I this is the last of
the stuff I ordered through soup YouTube
Nextup so definitely making videos a bit
better because Lighting's been a little
bit of an issue for me especially after
I broke about the other day yeah
Thank You YouTube so because of lights
been so busy recently I haven't had a
chance to eat cook so I've been living
off of leftovers and now I'm going left
so I'm in the student pub I ran on
campus for lunch I also just spent 10
pounds of new books because this
Blackwell's on campus and they were
doing three for two on stuff like this
on Liberty by Johnson now basically a
bunch of I got some Stewart mills and
Nietzsche and some dead cards so I'm not
read enough philosophy so I thought
they're bad time to start them now I'll
get one to read them in a couple of
months I just I have a problem with my
books I love fireworks
so things which happened today one it
turned out that the data file which I
ran on my computer in the office because
my laptop's been too slow was just
filled with nonsense for some reason
even though it works fine in my laptop
it doesn't work on my like the desktop
computer so
that was useless to a script which
worked perfectly fine on my laptop
yesterday I then run today and refused
to it actually refused to load in any
data at all like a basic command at the
start where I wants to open a data file
and I was like right just tell me what
longitude is this beta refused to do it
three I then tried to log into the
cluster which we have in the office for
sort of a large-scale computation which
is kind of what I need now and I could
log in however I didn't have necessary
permissions to move any files onto it so
it was useless having set that number
for one of the postdocs in the office
was very kind and sort of help me email
the right person because it's a little
bit sort of tricky to work out those
permissions stuff and help me sort of
get started with the cluster so and then
also actually look through my mitre and
was like yeah that's weird I don't know
what's doing that so thank you Stephen
so much for all of your help dudes and
how much for difference that made to my
morale he also ran my code on his
account on the cluster and it worked
fine so there's nothing wrong with the
code it's just my laptop which maybe
just on the blink because I've done
everything through it and running
everything locally and to be honest some
of these computations are pretty intense
like if you need to leave anything
running for like 36 hours you know
probably shouldn't be using a laptop for
it so fingers crossed
when I get back in on Monday and
actually even when I'm away this weekend
because I have mentioned that yet I
don't wait this weekend while I'm away
this weekend hopefully I'll get the
mission sorted tomorrow and I can
actually run stuff remotely by my laptop
so I think it'll be a bit quicker
I hope so it's nearly 7:00 p.m. I'm just
leaving campus now I've now got to do a
whole evenings worth of editing but
there's a lot to do and yeah I've got to
get up early tomorrow see my bread
finally completely broke so I'm
currently sleeping on the floor my room
in other words of Lily the other day
looks like it's from Trainspotting yeah
she's got a point so I now have two
things Twitter I have a podcast which
would take about hour to edit and then I
want to finish off in a 2000 subsequent
video because I haven't posted a video
in over a week and I feel a bit bad and
then I've got a pack because I am
cheating on a coach quarter past six and
I did not want to pack in the morning
and get up any earlier than I had to
[Music]
okay so the podcast is now edited um
that took longer than expected because
there was like an hour a half footage
and I had to find some music to put
underneath the fanfiction if you're not
aware we have a bunch of fanfiction
written about us my ass I mean Dan and I
so it is kind of late and I need so I'm
gonna pack and then I'll see how I feel
about editing because I'm honestly I
just want to get a little bit more sleep
because I'm up a half five tomorrow this
is surprisingly Jill and organized by my
standards done okay so it's currently
just gone past midnight as it stands I'm
getting a five hours sleep so I'm just
going to do a little bit of this that
I've got to go to bed whoops
I accidentally the whole video
frustrating me I don't want to release
this as is I wanna do titles now and in
music and it's now nearly won and I've
got to get up in four hours so I think I
probably better just capitulate whilst I
can right now I'm going to the Land of
Nod and in a couple of hours I'm gonna
start filming the most bizarre and
remarkable weekend I think of my life so
far I'll see you then
[Music]